هذه السفينه التي كانت حلما قبل سته اعوام
تحولت الى منزل عائم يجمع السايم 28 زميلا
مهمتهم محاربه التلوث
علمتني بلاستيك اوديسي سيمضون ثلاثه اعوام
يبحرون خلالها من بلد الى اخر في رحله
بحريه هدفها لحد من تلوث البحار والمحيطات
بالمواد البلاستيكيه
التي تذهب الى البحر عملنا على ايجاد
شركاء للتحضير للرحله التي بداناها من
مرسي الفرنسيه ومنها انطلقنا الى بيروت
كاول محطه خارج فرنسا
من اصحاب المبادرات البيئيه الذين
استقبلتهم السفينه على مدى اسبوعين لتبادل
الخبرات مع شركاء محليين والتعرف على احدث
الطرق لتدوير النفايات
بشكل ساعه
احنا عم بقدموا لنا اياها ممكن نقدر
نطبقه بلبنان باسمه
اه ممكن تضيع مثلا يستفيدوا من هالشي منه
مصنع كثير كبير لا يلبي مدينه بلبه ليشن
اصغر
بماكينات تحويل البلاستيك الى منتجات
يستفاد منها في رص الارصفه وبناء اسقف
المنازل ومواسير الصرف الصحي وحتى انتاج
الكهرباء في بلدان تعاني من الظلام مثل
لبنان لكن الهدف الاساسي هو الحد من
استخدام البلاستيك الذي يصب 20 طنا منه في
المحيطات كل دقيقه تغادر الانسي بيروت
متجهه نحو الاسكندريه في محطه ثانيه
سيتعرف خلالها طاقم السفينه على تجربه
جديده من معاناه المدن مع المواد
البلاستيكيه غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت